c'est une des plus vieilles recettes du
terroir tourangeau une poire gorgés de
soleil est plus hachée à la main et
déshydraté dans un four à bois
le fruit devient alors une poire tapée
cette gourmandise après ce que milan
longtemps disparu des assiettes
tourangelle la porte ap fait un retour
triomphal sur les tables des grands
restaurants grâce à des passionnés
la suggestion donc peut-être cassolette
de ris d'agneau trempette des bois aux
épices douces et le poisson au médaillon
de l'autre benoît pasquier est un chef
qui aime mettre en avant le patrimoine
culinaire locale et son terroir
originaire de chartres il est arrivé en
touraine il ya six ans quand il ouvre
son restaurant il découvre que la ville
n'a pas son pâté il décide alors de
créer le pâté de tours
à la base la cuisine c'est déjà une
valorisation déjà du savoir faire qu'on
nous a appris et surtout un savoir faire
local
on doit se considérer comme des
ambassadeurs de notre gastronomie dans
chaque région où on se trouve
si nous professionnels de la touraine où
on travaille pas déjà les produits de la
région qui le fera
pour concevoir son fameux pâté de tours
le chef va sélectionner les meilleures
spécialités de la touraine dans sa
recette on retrouve une belle farce à
base de porc et de vos de la géline de
racan et ce fruits déshydratés qu'on
appelle la poire tapée
j'ai cherché à avoir de la douceur un
côté sucré salé la douceur de la de la
volaille donc la chi linh de touraine le
côté moelleux du foie gras qui va être à
l'intérieur et puis le côté sucré de la
poire la poire est un produit donc
sécher qui va se réhydrater au fur et à
mesure de la cuisson
chaque bouchée va apporter un goût
différent et ça sera vraiment une
multitude de saveurs avec toutes ces
épices qui vont se se mélanger et qui
vont apporter un goût vraiment cheap et
sûr pour ce pâté le pâté de tours aux
poires tapées avec une gelée ou vrai je
vous souhaite un bon appétit
ce que j'ai apprécié par dessus tout
c'est justement cette poire tapée la
caisse et une originalité disons parce
qu on est plus habitué à la fille et
c'est le père c'est une poire n'y a pas
su trouver mais nos dents mais familière
ça sent comme le citron vous voyez c'est
très intéressant
donc c'est une fois ok nous ne savions
pas je ne savais pas c'est vraiment
unique
non content à cela à singapour même si
nous allons dans les restaurants
français mais c'est très authentique
très locale oui c'est très bon
je
tous
la poire tapée cette vieille spécialité
tourangelle commence à refaire son
chemin dans les assiettes
il y a vingt ans qui aurait dit que
cette recette de fruits séchés datant du
moyen-âge se retrouverait sur les tables
des grands restaurants
car la poire tapée a bien failli
disparaître mais c'était sans compter
sur le sursaut de quelques tourangeau
amoureux de ce morceau de patrimoine
gastronomique rivarennes petit village
niché entre langer et azay le rideau
c'est ici qu'est née la recette
d'apparence simple il faut pourtant une
semaine pour transformer une poire en
poire tapée
c'est l'une des plus anciennes méthodes
de conservation du fruit un procédé qui
lui n'a pas changé avec le temps
tous les lundis la semaine commence par
le même rituel dans cette entreprise
familiale
l'épluchage des poires et qu'elle des
eaux d'oran nathalie marie claude et les
autres et peluches à la main 65 kg de
fruits par semaine manuellement c'est
beaucoup plus régulier qu'avec les
fameuses machines qui existent sur le
marché
ce que toute façon après faut passer
vont recommencer après les machines la
plupart du temps donc à la main ça va
bien plus vite à l'ancienne dans la
pièce d'à côté emmanuel s'affairent car
une fois que les poires sont épluchés et
placés sur des clés ses caissettes
grillagée elles seront enfournez dans un
four à bois
il faut monter le four à température
régulière pour faire un coup de chaud et
après plus rien sinon les poires avons
faire un coût de 2,2 flétrie il faut
qu'elle soit des idrac
encore une fois ce soir a bien brûlé
j'écarte sûrs et surtout la brève au
milieu pour passer un point chaud au
niveau de maths l'est que je mettrai
plus tard
autrement les poires ont brûlé il faut
qu'à se déshydrate toujours ces
artisanes hals et c'est pas demain la
patate et moi je connaissais pas comme
tout le monde de nom mais qu'est ce que
c'est
garder ce côté artisanal c'est essentiel
pour philippe blot avec sa femme
cet ancien d'aiguilleurs du ciel à la
retraite a créé son entreprise de
production de poires tapées en 2004
quand on est arrivé ici à rivarennes en
a acheté la ferme là pour pouvoir la
restaurer et puis on s'est inscrit à une
association c'était l'association de
l'appart ap et à partir de là on a
appris à faire des poires tapées donc ma
femme a voulu se mettre à travailler
faire un petit truc a demandé est ce que
tu veux me suivre j'ai dit oui et puis
on est parti et c'est parti comme ça
on fait tout à la main depuis la sortie
des frigos jusqu'à l'étiquetage la
fermeture des pots tout est fait à la
main
ça apporte plusieurs choses ont déjà le
contrôle qualité se fait en permanence
et puis ça aussi l'autre l'autre
avantage c'est de garder ce côté ce côté
anciens qu'on perdrait avait en
utilisant la machine beaucoup plus que
ça si philippe blot est autant attaché à
l'image d'antan de cette spécialité
locale
c'est parce qu'elle est chargée
d'histoire pour taper deux tours il
n'est pas hors de propos d'observer que
ses pruneaux et ses pouvoirs ne sont pas
pu se préparer à tour que les marrant
qu'on vend sous le nom de baron lyon ne
sont récoltés sur toi cette ville donc
on en 1995
au 19ème siècle la commercialisation des
poires tapées s'intensifie y est à son
apogée
on estime qu'à cette époque la
production locale se situe à plus de 150
tonnes de fruits séchés par an à la fin
de la première guerre mondiale commence
le déclin du produit la modernisation
des procédés de conservation grâce à
l'électricité
la généralisation des réfrigérateurs va
précipiter cette chute dans les années
30 la poire tapée disparaît totalement
de rivarennes il faudra attendre 1988
pour voir renaître cette gourmandise
dans le village les grands parents de
jean ray brescia originaire du coin
faisait de la poire tapée pour leur
consommation personnelle
moi j'ai gardé un souvenir d'enfance ma
grand-mère à jour m'a dit je vais te
faire goûter les parts ap et donc j'ai
mangé une poire sur le coup j'étais un
peu étonné entre le mot qui me semblait
préparer une friandise quoi et puis la
réalité j'avais été légèrement déçus
mais j'ai gardé le souvenir de ce goût
de ce côté aigrelet de la poire j'avais
8 ans peut-être 8 novembre au début des
années 80 george revient s'installer
dans le village
bon je me souvenais que rivarennes
faisait les portes ap j'avais lu dans un
livre en plus que j'avais acheté à
c'était merveilleux c'était plus un mais
absolument divin c'est extraordinaire
bon mais il ajouté toujours mais c'est
pas facile à faire
comment retrouver le procédé de
fabrication autrefois les hauts plateaux
de rivarennes étaient couverts de
vergers aujourd'hui il ne reste que ses
poiriers centenaires abandonné vestiges
d'une époque où la poire tapée
représenter 80% ressources du village
georges frêche a s'est donc tourné vers
les anciens etc léontine guillon qui
leur a révélé la recette sont quand même
cédé points des points lecture ou encore
marc collin porte et qui met pas toutes
espèces en général c'est à du corps ma
roue du tueur et les faire bouillir dans
la chaudière
mais fallait est un certain moment
fallait jusqu'à temps que ça jette sans
béton alors après on lime trempé sud est
clair et on les éplucher et puis après
au soir en lisant fournel la haye foule
à pingouins sur les recommandations de
léontine les membres de l'association se
sont lancés j'aime quand on sait que
c'est très enthousiaste à on a toutes
tous bien fait on s'est bien appliqué on
a bien ranger nos pouvoirs sur l'éclair
on a tout enfourner quoi c'est le
propriétaire est donc à tout enfourner
comme un grand dans un four qui était
bien chaud bien bien chaud très chaud
est tellement chaud qu'on a tout brûlé
bon c'était la catastrophe c'était les
boules et de charbon
on aurait pu baisser les bras mais non
non on était tenu quand même par quelque
chose on n'avait jamais briser certaines
phases donc on s'est dit ah moins deux
raisons la russie
christine et rhin met la dernière touche
à l'un de ses produits phares la foire
taper aux vins de chinon
avec son mari ils se sont installés ici
en 1995
ils sont les premiers à s'être lancé
dans la production de poires tapées avec
les blu ils sont les seuls producteurs
de rivarennes au départ nos étés en
tailleur de pierre on a acheté la maison
pour ça et il a fallu arrêter à taille
de pierre en deux mois avec deux ans de
boulot d'avant ce pour raisons de santé
les gens du musée sont venus nous voir
en nous demandant si on accepter leur
prêter les fours on a dit oui et c'est
maxime production quelque part qui nous
nous a toujours interpellé mais c'est
qu'on était tailleur de pierres au
départ donc on est quand même très lié
avec le terroir quand même et ensuite
d'accord on avait arrêté la taille de
pierre il fallait qu'on fasse quelque
chose et en a galéré pendant trois
quatre ans et au bout de trois quatre
ans est rendu compte que dans les
troglodytes y avait tout pour faire pour
taper on a osé le faire
vingt ans après christine hérail son
mari ont complètement transformé les
lieux ils ont créé des laboratoires pour
confectionner des produits à base de
pois retaper une boutique un espace
dégustation on s'est rendu compte que
les gens avaient du mal à s'imaginer
tout ce que l'on pouvait faire avec la
porte ap donc c'était à nous en tant que
producteur de leur montrer donc les
essais personnels ont basculé sur le
centre prise
chez les bleus aussi on s'est mis à
cuisiner les poires tapées aux vins de
touraine une recette parmi tant d'autres
et je vais remuer pour mélanger mon
sucre et les poires voilà
on a refait toute une gamme en utilisant
bien sûr les verts locaux donc les
appellations d 1,2 g retrouver surtout
des vieilles recettes qui remontaient
fatras zié 13ème 14ème siècle et à
partir de là je me suis dit on va
essayer de les remettre au goût du jour
ton
cela fait maintenant trois jours que nos
poire enfourner lundi se déshydrate dans
les fours il est temps de les retourner
pour une deuxième chauffe bons joueurs
ça donne quoi
bon bah c'est bien là on est sur un des
six fours qu'on exploite actuellement
c'est un fourre dans la d'un particulier
qui nous est prêtée à la grande époque
de la porte après il ya eu jusqu'à 80
four en activité dans le village et ils
disparaissaient tous plus ou moins
détruits soit par manque d'entretien
soit parce qu'ils n'étaient pas utilisés
et on s'est dit mais après tout on sait
travailler dans les vieux four autant
les sauver et les garder en étapes
alors les traits qu'on s'entraîne
génétiquement afin qu'un massage et syfy
les blu s'est donné pour mission de
garder la tradition intacte christian
guérin a dû moderniser le procès d une
nécessité après la disparition de son
mari elle n'utilise presque plus de four
à bois mais un séchoir spécialement
conçu pour la poire tapée la première
tournée dans la forêt avec le sait fort
l'avait vraiment très très peur on l'a
fait boutet nos enfants demain a réagi
sur très bonne y'a pas y avait il n'y a
pas de différents arts il n'y a pas de
différence puisqu'on a mis les mêmes
paramètres que des fours à bois
donc chaque variété à son programme
chaque programme à ces phases et chaque
phase aller qu'à aller paramètres et on
a gardé 120 à 130 heures déshydratation
et en les tombes pareil
nos poire se déshydrate depuis environ
120 heures en cinq jours elles ont perdu
80 % d'humidité divisant leur poids par
set
il faut désormais les plats tir comme
disaient les anciens et c'est avec cet
engin que les poires deviennent des
poires tapis avant l'étape et soit avec
la paume des mains sont avec le pouce et
l'index
donc ça ça très bien marché pendant des
années après dans les années 1860 1162
le phylloxéra est arrivé il a fallu
arracher tout est fini et d'autres qui
se sont retrouvés avec un moyen de
subsistance en moins donc c'est pour ça
en fait le rivarennes a construit des
fours parce qu'il fallait bien équilibré
ce manque de production et la taper
l'épauler poids avec les paumes des
mains et le pouce et index à c'était un
peu un petit peu difficile quand même
donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont créé
l'apathie soir hélas 2014
on a on peut pas faire mieux que les
petits soient non non c'est bien ça ce
sont des outils mais fait maison c'est
bien ça c'est bon
en 20 ans à peine la poire tapée remise
en fabrication par deux producteurs
passionnés à retrouver une seconde vie
aujourd'hui leur production a été
multipliée par dix par rapport à leurs
débuts mais l'existence de la spécialité
locale reste fragile et pourrait
disparaître à nouveau des fois même à
vallini qui en a eu d'autres qui
s'installe en cependant de profiter de
la dynamique qu'on a commencé à
instituer pour pouvoir parce que une
concurrence saine et loyale
c'est le moteur du commerce
c'est vrai que ça serait dommage que ça
s'arrête
ça fait déjà arrêté dans les années 30
ça serait dommage que ça s'arrête à
nouveau
peut-être que ça va intéresser d'autres
générations mon petit fils par exemple
la petite fille on sait pas l'espoir
fait vivre
il reste moins par ici vous savez une
chose me réjouis quand on parle du
produits locaux on nous parle des
produits emblématiques de la touraine
vous avez les rillettes de tours le
sainte-maure-de-touraine et la porte
appel rival à chaque fois et ça c'est au
delà au delà de ce qu'on pouvait espérer
les séries
il raté
incroyable en effet l'histoire de cette
poire tapée produit si banal dans le
passé et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui sur
les plus grandes tables de france et du
monde